do you have a product management
interview lined up in this case you want
to demonstrate that you can successfully
prioritize a great PM needs to know how
to say no to many different ideas in
order to say yes to the few really good
ones show interviewers thought you can
prioritize by providing examples from
your product management experience was
there a time when you chose to focus on
customer retention over Market expansion
for example and why demonstrate how you
use data to make sound prioritization
decisions one method that I like to use
is Impact versus effort where you
compare the impact or the value that
this product or this feature is going to
drive for your customer and compare it
with the effort that it's going to take
to build and ship this feature remember
no matter which method you use to
prioritize you must tie it back to the
product strategy goals and success
criteria